diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit der
camembert cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Musik]
mein vater gehörte als kaminfeger zur
zunft der glücksbringer
überall wurden die kaminfeger in berufs
uniform gerne eingeladen
ihm selber aber brachte seinen beruf
kein glück hier ein gläschen mit den
kunden und dort ein kaffee schnaps mit
den kollegen
in den 50er und 60er jahren war es
üblich dass man während der arbeitszeit
tranken und das wurde ihm zum verhängnis
bitte schuhe es halt einfach unschön
gesehen dass wir derart durchgeführt hat
das dann bei allen eltern sehen dann hat
der haupt soja warum diesmal mieter
zieht merkt sie aber wenn sie nur
eisfläche grund gehabt
das ist neben wirkt der braucht sie
irgendwann braucht wenn man vor der
zahler versucht schweiz skoda seit das
verwundert dass die kinder der schweiz
in der familie lagers alkoholproblem
gibt was hat der fußball das im winter
bei zwei jahre diese kinder in der
familie großes alkoholproblem geht und
wir jetzt mal so rechnet drittel wurden
die kinder eines problems 800 gene sind
therapie sie 50 wie unsere handlich
[Musik]
über 40 jahre ist es her seit mein vater
starb
er fehlt zu hause die treppe hinunter da
er alleine wohnte blieb sein sturz
unbemerkt und er blieb mehrere tage
liegen
diesen unfall überlebte er nicht er
wurde 47 jahre alt ich war knapp 16
und ich erinnere mich dass ich damals
geweint habe aber nicht falle gestorben
war sondern weil es mir nichts mehr aus
machte dass er tot war
meine mutter hat denen zehn jahre vorher
verlassen
während all dieser jahre ist er für mich
ein fremder geworden
[Musik]
auch die kindheit der heute 16-jährigen
magdalena ist geprägt vom alkoholkonsum
eines elternteils nach suizidversuchen
und einem irrweg durch heime und
kliniken ist sie vor drei jahren in
einem sozial pädagogisch betreuten
wohnheim im kandertal gelandet sie
möchte sich vor der kamera nicht ganz
offen zeigen der kaiser durch und
kontostand plan wo das kritik will
abraham sobald sie dann immer in
erinnerung dass seine trunkenheit
mein papi vorgegangen
das ist eine andere wohnung sucht der
geschädigten hat mit public schreibt
denn jetzt halt zeigt sich es ist vor
allem bei man versteht ihn haben brad
leeb dem pult minute zählt vor allem
will ich trainer series 7
[Musik]
waren dabei das sind sehr familie und
sind sie da von der persönlich ganz
bestimmt eigentlich immer zum schlafen
grüner nachschau sehr stammt aus der
heimat läuft will aber nicht beamte der
hayek 7
sie muss auch schön ruft sie und so und
ältere sind halt auch in ganz ganz
anders
[Musik]
die entbehrungen eine kindheit mit einem
alkoholkranken elternteil können
menschen lebenslänglich prägen
davon erzählt mir monika b in der
familie geboren wurde dritter vor auch
kinder und wir sind sehr sehr betrunken
engagement kohl grips und verdunkelt
sehr häufig besser zügeln will mit ihnen
kann derzeit werden sind zuletzt in der
mark boulos konnten es ist sehr
bedrückte stimmig sie die frische ideen
aber betrunken und aggressiv gegen
betrunkene mutter immer geschlagen
werden die im oberen stock geschlafen
dann bin ich zum fenster raus und bin im
schlafzimmer 50 uhr passierte denen und
den hätte vater mutter will er würde und
dass fast alle mit der hand und europe
online casino sie und die bindet
erfolgsspur
[Musik]
militärische geforderte sie mit kind und
zerstörung ist keine punkte sie hat
einfach edith buskohl
[Musik]
die haben ganz schwarzer kann und man
ihm zum reden und dem platz ruhe
gefunden
das wasser
das ist ein baum
[Musik]
punkt nicht das ist so wie ihr umgeht
das ist auch nicht so gut
der ruhe
ja
einfach frieden finden
[Musik]
bei der integrierten suchthilfe in
winterthur treffe ich den
kinderpsychologen georg klingt das
therapeutische angebot zebra fokussiert
ihr ganz auf die bedürfnisse von kindern
und jugendlichen
dmc brauchen mehr kinder aus allen
schichten und aus allen alters nur fünf
bis acht jahre mein soziales sind aber
mein drittes wirklich sehr gut
situierter
[Musik]
schmale spions jetzt mit therapeutisch
sondern diesmal hatte sowie und spaß
machen die kinder ist einfach nur so
dass eine gegenüber optische sah mich
sehr schwierig zu treten und ganz oft
gut als reden allgemeine dhb spielt man
einfach und versuchte situation in deren
art stelle wo man dann noch das
kommunizieren
in familien mit einem alkoholkranken
eltern teil richtet sich die
aufmerksamkeit auf den süchtigen die
kindlichen bedürfnisse gehen vergessen
die not dieser kinder steht bei zebra im
vordergrund heute ist so wie bei georg
kling in therapie ihr vater starb vor
drei jahren an seiner alkoholkrankheit
was genau ist eigentlich die einzige
musik
[Musik]
nur ein drittel aller kinder aus
suchtkranken familien schafft es ein
leben ohne sucht und psychische
beeinträchtigungen zu führen
das risiko dieser kinder selber sucht
krank zu werden ist sechsmal höher als
in gesunden familienstrukturen
kinder wie vor ganz klein extrem
schwierige situation erlaube und auch
weil zu mitspieler lagen die an oft
größere problematischer psychische
problematik in ihrem leben
[Musik]
unserer meinung nach wird das oft sehr
unterschätzt vor allem was das internet
[Musik]
als meine eltern heirateten wusste meine
mutter dass mein vater zu viel trank sie
war jedoch überzeugt dass sie ihm helfen
kann und er damit aufhörte sobald er
familie hat die bemühungen meiner mutter
meinem vater vom trinken abzuhalten
waren jedoch vergeblich nach dem vierten
kind sah sie dass ein und überließ ihn
seinem schicksal alleine rutscht er
immer tiefer ins elend
[Musik]
die trennung meiner eltern
er spart es mir und meinen geschwistern
den zerfall unseres vaters aus der nähe
mitzuerleben
für magdalena war es schwieriger sie
hielt die situation zu hause nicht mehr
aus darauf legt dass sie so irgendwie
checkt den hat sie nochmals 100
mit der schule ist eine burg laufe der
heißen gut gelaufen anhalt will auch gar
kein fußball gefunden
danach machen versucht umbringen und so
wir haben nach damals gereizt und
blutete und das spiel hat man halt die
käufer soll ich bin da ich glaube noch
so scheint sie erst einmal wonach
dunkelhaarig mit titanic sie ist alles
verschwommen und irgendwie scheint egal
stimmt nicht und das ist super denn
mit call vermutlich ab und zu einfach
mal so voll ist kein effekt
die zeit dem wohnheim half magdalena
ihre situation besser zu verstehen
sie realisierte dass sie ihr leben
ändern muss
er weiß nur dass ich meine sie danach
als einer woche wieder aus elfenbein
haltbar gedrückt und hab mal über alles
[Musik]
hallo schön im moment mit erika bei mir
mit sammelt zum coiffeur sind und es
erstmalig statt
händler halten doch staffel sind durch
den schön
[Musik]
damit mein auto machen eine lehre als
automesse auto mobil fachfrau eine halbe
jahr weihnachten autos und dann mache
ich die standbetreiber ja
[Musik]
wir sind immer glocke der schule denn
das einfach immer gelacht
frische süße und zielpunkt und so für
sinnlos was ausgelagert werden
das ist simpson schnee liegt und noch
fragt was machen die großen in dir
wir sind einfach mitgegangen und
meistens am 3 und eigentlich einmal im
weiteren haus gestorben und händler die
wall street hat es getan hat - close
fahrzeuge und das bild gemacht und
einfach ohne gewürze
ich habe mich einstellung von mir machen
vorschriften machen und so und scheren
im alten wirt und einfach am besten mit
des grauens sehen sind
das ich in der fünften klasse
da nicht immer verbessern will ich mich
selber kostete habe mich geschämt dass
ich habe durch das habe ich geschafft
mini älterer für mich versicherung
krankheit und immer gehört du bist so
blöd und du bist so doof
angenehmes gefühl ich bin schlecht ich
bin boes akademisch das meer aussieht
das ist schrecklich gefühlt
[Musik]
die allermeisten kreisläufer laen
irgendwie schuld oder verantwortlich das
bringt mir fast nicht lang
[Musik]
uns ist ganz wichtig dass kinder
bescheid wissen was denn für erkranken
dann versucht er krank weil das für die
meisten kinder große entlastung ist das
erstellte größte angst dass nutztiere
das hast du mir noch mal verzeihen
gestorben ist also ich bin jedoch
versteht wieso und seht ihr das dann
verzählt das ist wegen alkohol ist ja
das hätte nach dem wetter um ihre mutter
obwohl sie 20 sie zu
natürlich dachte sich wohl ein
historisches wie es gezeigt für den
wachstums und boni vaterstolz problem
fand realisiert wie schlimm das
elektrisch und den harry potter
kontrolliert also machen dort vom vater
man ganz viel gefühl karibik sie hatte
doch bis die wir mit dir viel früher
rückseite die was den fortgang kritisch
und das bka habe sie das ist von mir
später ansteht typisch also bestellt ist
also eine alkoholabhängigkeit stecken
denn dann sind sie was mir wüsste nicht
dass kinder oder ältere versucht hat ein
größeres risiko hängt also die summe
giftiger als problem über für
zusätzliches sie gut sehr offen und sehr
direkt mit den schwierigkeiten um
sehr interessiert lösungen zu finden und
damit sie sehr gut der grünen den
charakter und das triple eigentlich
erhofft
[Musik]
vielen kindern merkt man die
schwierigkeiten die sie zu hause haben
nicht an weil sie in gedanken oft daheim
sind gelten sie als unkonzentriert oder
sie sind über angepasst
diese waren signale werden
missverstanden oder ganz übersehen wenn
es in der schule gut funktioniert wird
schule nicht reagieren und es passiert
ist eine progressive im winter so muss
leider denkt sieht man das in der kabine
reagieren
[Musik]
in monikas familie schaltete sich die
behörde ein als die mutter für eine
weitere geburt im spital war
kind geboren und ist schwester die mit
dem billy beschützt sich die ganz nach
mit dem bier liter hoch gestanden wie
oscar gewonnen
ich behaupte ich sehe wo die behördlich
und ist randvoll genannt ich mag mich
nur innerlich bei dem eine zimmerecke
links und da habe ich einfach weil
verstecken dass mich nicht mehr sieht
und kurzen texten und ich habe meine
mutter nur eine stoffwechsel bevor das
man noch ein 11 fleck familien verteilt
worden sind
noch jahre kann ich noch herr im
[Musik]
winterlager kopieren halle und die
gestanden
die mutter verstanden nicht auszuhalten
darum muss die die familie aufgelöst
werden
wir hätten ihn die motorwelle haushalte
wie hat sie werde bis machen wenn ihr
kalt und nass
hauptproblem das süße so beschissen ist
der alkoholkonsum in sachsen
das ist das hauptproblem
[Musik]
vier jahre später hat die mutter gegen
den widerstand der behörden monika aus
der pflegefamilie wieder zurück nach
hause geholt
[Musik]
wie geplant hat magdalena vor einem
halben jahr ihre lehre als automobil
fachfrau begonnen und ist vom heim in
eine wg gezogen
der neue alltag ist für sie eine
herausforderung und eine charmante
betreuerin und eine schon sonstigen
bedeutet wenn mir da zu machen und so
stehen der fachbereiche wie so gelaufen
ist forderte supersexy dann merkt man
hat mir alle sind nachhallzeit mit mir
müssen irgendwie alles angeschaut und
jetzt heißt einfach denn denn da sind
das war ein tank ist gut wenn etwa das
ja ich stehe jeden tag an für vier
monaten auf damit der halben jahres an
arbeitsmarkt vor 50 minuten
wir müssen wir über alles gehe ich habe
auch der start in ihrer ausbildung ist
für magdalena in vielerlei hinsicht
nicht einfach die ganze schuld der
hofkirche attika
selbst als vier sanitäter es halt nicht
ganz da
wir behandeln die analytica passiven
hintergrund hat der mini mitarbeiter
das einzige was dem heim bis zur
vergangenheit ist eigentlich nie thema
und damit bemitleidet werden
[Musik]
ich bin bis 55 kilo schwere gesehen als
sie jetzt das ist für mich schon
dann passierte was es ist wir haben eine
pizza kasse
[Musik]
ich habe mir das schöne kleid kaufen
doch der pilot verlor
ich habe einfach einmal wendet höre ich
habe mich jahrelang stand und einfach in
der minderheit
[Musik]
wenn nicht das 50 spieltage
denn shooter hat mich das fast wenn ich
sehe wie nichts gesehen hat dass ich
mich gar nicht bewusst gesehen
[Musik]
minute genau richtig sie innerlich aber
einfach österreich mit dem schönen kleid
einfach zumal wir uns vor allem ich habe
mir das leichter
obwohl ich mir das versprochene
finanzielle
irgendwo ist das gar nicht so gepasst
von österreich aber innerlich sehr sehr
gut
das ist richtig es mehr gefechte
[Musik]
und eine schöne zeit und natürlich auf
die wunderschöne stadt
[Musik]
versucht der kranke sich ganz auf das
große familie geheimnis mehr erfahren
schwierige situation erst wenn es ein
behördlicher werk das wie ein polizist
als zum beispiel die icsi ist und selbst
stört werde mir oft gelogen dass kinder
sogar auf erzählen es ist alles in
ordnung sie und ihre worden später vor
der bühne standen
es sind drei polizisten gewalt in der
familie ist
[Musik]
so wagte der unternehmer die kinder mit
ariel trasse für das was sich hinter
island und das ist überhaupt hätte so
die kinder sind deinen eltern gegenüber
immer extrem loyal die stirn zu ihren
eltern
wird die note für kinder und jugendliche
zu groß bieten die beraterinnen und
berater der stiftung pro juventute über
die telefon nummer 147 hilfe an
[Musik]
alle angebote kostenlos und vertraulich
also musiker waren risch und ihm so
nicht sagen wo man berühmt wir sind
jeden tag eins bis zwei sind wahrlich
dazu dem thema alkoholsucht die familie
nehmen und mit den konflikten
[Musik]
trotz aktie ist immer die frage der
schutz bringt wichtig dass es der
situation mit wieder ausgesetzt ist und
noch vorlauf dass es verletzte gibt und
wenn du live klose übersichtlicher
folkwang als türe zumachen wenn das kind
sich mal wirklich suizidgedanken oder
suizid handle gemacht wird
organisiere ich werde geändert
[Musik]
mit hits war es schwierig sich auf ca
sie hat einfach zu wenig motivation kann
sie hätte fußach es normal wenn lisa es
gab weniger geschaffen das problem
einfach wie taxi gute sachen wo auch
nicht funktionieren
im berufsleben kann dass ich so etwas
kann muss alles ich habe mir schon
bewiesen wir nicht langt also das ist ja
so ein spiel mit sprache brauchen
wohnraum klar gemacht dass das so nicht
geht hat sie realisiert bzw kontraktes
erinnerung mexiko betrat das seda so
schafft die grüne jahr die
abschlussberichte
[Musik]
es ist donnerstagabend und magdalena hat
besuch von darius omlin ihren betreuer
aber der noch nicht so gut funktioniert
das wäre spannend
ich habe nie darüber funktionieren auch
noch ein zwei monate chef zeigt dass
ihre quasi jegliche grundlage feiert vom
schreiber vom von der mechanik material
ton licht und und und und mein mann kann
es richtig wenn sie jetzt mit werkzeug
mitteile und den aktuellen stück papier
das neue und die lachen
doch jetzt ergänzen
[Musik]
friede und überlege mir nicht merkt es
ist schließlich habe nicht so sie tragen
wieder mal irgendwie mein ganzes leben
management emotionen aber gerade vor
stetig sie über sich selber situation
war verwundert es gar nicht und er
wundert sich auch als problem das ist
ein wirkliches von 12x muss man sagen
aber das ist sehen wir dass die zeit
gegen jugendrat und und deswegen ja als
fünf vor zwölf jahren blut oder
hoffentlich
[Musik]
nach der scheidung meiner eltern sahen
wir unseren vater nur noch am
monatlichen besuch sonntag
er holte uns ab und fuhr mit uns ins
wirtshaus diese sechs stunden haben wir
einfach abgesessen
neben ihm am stammtisch zu sagen hatte
er uns immer weniger
[Musik]
mein vater war ein gutmütiger mensch er
war nie gewalttätig aber irgendwie war
er auch nie richtig da eher entspannt
jahr für jahr ein wenig mehr in seinem
alkohol nebel
das ist die letzte aufnahme von ihm
bevor er mit 47 jahren starb ihr
geschäft und er würde mir das auto zur
stelle
im moment läuft es gut in der garage
damit das so bleibt versucht darius
omlin herauszufinden was der grund für
das schwierige erste halbe jahr war die
situation ist frauen das traurig dass
ich damit ja inzwischen auch sie kann
mit einem passiert woran machen sie
machen das leben schwer
und dass ich glaube mit dem chef genau
gleich alle drei systeme den verbraucher
konfrontiert da nicht mehr stehen im
raum
ja genau mit der museologe stand logisch
vom alkoholkranken vater wechselte
monika fast nahtlos zu einem
alkoholkranken ehemann
heute ist sie geschieden und stolz auf
ihre drei erwachsenen töchter das ist
[Musik]
wenn ich nur mit meiner ex partner
zusammen klappt aber nicht immer denkt
kennt merkt an ich weiß das klingt das
gespürt die merke ich das ganz
instinktiv spürt unterschwellig und
spanien sind und das hat mich tief
beschämt dass sie sich das nicht auch
ein erfahrener autovermieter sind und
das mini wo sie wohnen zusammengebrochen
sind
ich habe immer das beste werferin
[Musik]
ich bin höchst persönlich sehr froh
wiederholt sich die biographien sind
dass sie schafften es alle gruppen leben
wenn ich mich grossartig spüren diese
dankbarkeit dass sie es oder verfassen
und das macht mir freude und wir haben
einen großen
[Musik]
der geburt gebe mehr
und da hat im sand kostet fehlt es
machen china vergeben
chemische verfahren dass er jedes mal
ein oder gewaltszenen darstellt und
mexiko tourismus studium braucht die
haben den markt kommt warum macht es
eigentlich war ja das passiert hat da
warten zurück dann habe ich selber
nochmals einer geschichte oder eine
situation oder hey passiert ist das
motto sind hoch ich sehe
irgendwie so mache und ich mache und ich
schaute hoch und dann kommt hat das seco
mich gelaufen oder und text so komisch
geleckt und dann geht da mit dem
motorrad fortschritte plötzlich zeigt
ein stück historie jetzt konnte der
ödnis und sich plötzlich der vater sechs
jahre schreibung sieglosen wirklich auf
dem abschluss und beruf für ruf verruf
los man in ruhe und ob ihr kind einfach
nur eine ganz starke stücke und sich ins
zimmer und überhaupt nicht bis zum
hersteller sally mache ich konnte den
fakt dass tankstellen was wäre lösung
nicht zu den eltern ohne unterhose
gefunden damals große webseiten
und natürlich nie mehr macht für mich
ist eigentlich jetzt durch die djkler
ich muss eine sonder oder ich muss nicht
mit dem schimpfen sondern muss mit den
familien oder so vor allem mit dem mord
oder was sie machen wenn es eine
gefährliche situationen stand
mit dem team aus dusche über schwere und
komplexität ist so wichtig für unser
angebot ist das meer mit anderen
fachstellen fans sind man das hilft uns
natürlich gerade wenn sehr komplexe
situationen sind dörte der durchblick zu
und bessere unterstützung schließlich
wald mehrfach passiert ist sogar schon
einiges gesehen also für retweet und ja
das ist stand der sonne ersten
gesprächen mit nur drei sekunden
ich werde vielleicht ein windiger börsig
hatte mit der anderer stelle unter
verschluss der kleine denn schon
aufwendig als sieben das war damit 78
ist er denn wissen wie irgendwas in der
schule ist er da schon auffällig
geworden oder haben die ganz gab es da
schon rückmeldung ja also sie mit der
schule und ich wünsche euch einen kurzen
telefonischen eigentlichen darüber
erbost
unsere hauptaufgabe des chirurgen also
das heißt wir sind fürs kind da das
schild besser gott und nicht für die
[Musik]
kinder findet was therapeut bucht weiter
und damit ins hospiz usa wollten
[Musik]
bismark sind ich jetzt einfach einige
monate und erde ganz eigentlich gut zu
trinken haben auch weniger als früher
trinken immer noch aber es ist jetzt im
griff so zeug
am wochenende leider bin
[Musik]
und danach dann der nächste halt danach
lässt also sex ist eigentlich so
schwierig
ich brauche dafür sollen drei starts und
teil
[Musik]
die zapfstelle gruppe und der toni
erklärt dass ich erwarte dass ich weit
vorbei das was ich mich darf muss er
schnell und er stelle ich mich denn mit
solid unterhalten plötzlich gemerkt dass
sie nicht willens schwachen lütow so fit
sondern sie sind krank und er strich das
könne aber aus kranke pavillon mit dem
economic sentiment dass man ist mit der
junge gemerkt und handel untersagt
das ist eine schule das wirke sich müsse
gestoppt
die machtlosigkeit das ist schlimm
sie müssen sage ich mit dem alkohol und
im alkoholika gegenüber machtlos
ich will mir gar kontrolliert haben wir
das gefühl auf dass alles aus dem ruder
und ich habe ja alles zusammen und zu
uns
[Musik]
die harmlosere der selbsthilfegruppe
mitnehmen können über das reden dass er
verstanden und da nicht angefangen
zudem hatten und dann habe ich gemerkt
dass mir lichter löschen
[Musik]
wenn ich einem emotionalen absturz das
geht so hüttemann und den erklärt dass
ich noch haare zur krone mit dem sich
button und so wieder auf die probe zum
mittag und einfach mehr aufgegangen
durch findet sie
st
waschen
prüfer - für stück diesem stube dann
eingeführte mit tricks geht nach alkohol
und kokain park tip und rannte mit 26
jahren rettungsmethoden die anders
monikas eltern sind schon lange
verstorben
ihr vater hat jahre vor seinem tod
aufgehört zu trinken es ergaben sich
gespräche über früher die monika nie für
möglich gehalten hätte auch mit ihrer
mutter konnte sie sich versöhnen bevor
diese starke welle geboren und das finde
ich erschreckend sehr schwarz live
account ist aber ganz elend gegangen
[Musik]
und ich rede sein
du hast dies möglich stück macht das
beste gemacht
das ist ihr können rösler ja und da hat
sie mich erst einmal nicht bewusst weiß
und der mich seit ich hatte glück dass
ich froh bin ich zumindest marketing und
so habe ich mich riesig
der schliersee moral
[Musik]
im sommer drei monate nach unserem
letzten treffen habe ich erfahren dass
magdalena ihre ausbildung abgebrochen
hat es war für sie wohl alles ein wenig
viel auf einmal
auch die beziehung zu ihrem freund ging
in die brüche nun ist sie zurück im
wohnheim im kaunertal wohin ihr weg gibt
ist offen
[Musik]
alkohol ist ein kulturgut doch der
übergang vom genuss zur sucht ist
fließend das wird unterschätzt und
verharmlost nicht nur zur zeit meiner
kindheit auch heute noch vor jahren
während einer persönlichen krise habe
ich gelernt meinen vater besser zu
verstehen
sr trägt sich im moment durch vieles
leichter nach einem glas wein aber
leider nur für den moment
[Musik]
jede woche mindestens drei alkoholfreie
tage darüber wache ich akribisch eine
strichliste in der agenda amüsiert
bisweilen meine freundinnen und freunde
und auch ich schmunzeln manchmal über
meine kontrolliert hat
so hat mich das schicksal meines vaters
bis heute geprägt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von der genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
der camembert cremiger genuss seit 1902